all right the past five years have given
players time to come up with some really
advanced tactics and complicated
glitches to take out breath of the
wild's foes with style but today we're
dialing it back a little bit and going
with the easiest simplest tricks to take
on these enemies including hinox talus
lionels guardians and more
some glitches will be used but these are
very simple tricks that don't require
any previous knowledge and are easy to
do if you prefer this type of content
let us know in the comments below
to start off if you see high knocks with
anklets either wooden or metallic these
can be used to repeatedly stun them over
and over if you see one with metal
anklets spring preferably a great
thunderblade swing the blade and drop
the weapon mid-swing to give them shock
properties on the ground then magnesis
it and plop it down right next to the
hinox's leg now you can literally do
whatever you want as long as the blade
is in range it's completely stunned
the wooden anklet is not quite as
abusable but can still give you multiple
chances to distract them simply shoot a
fire arrow at its leg then put it out
with a blizzard rod or ice arrow to
recycle its use
another easy trick is permanent active
hitbox and although this does work
against any enemy it's generally more
effective against guardians and high
knocks by mounting a master cycle or
horse then going at sprinting speeds
attacking holding jump mid attack then
canceling by pressing b your weapon will
now constantly do damage as it's
equipped and can be abused in several
different ways like holding attack with
spear near guardians to bulldoze right
through them
or just spam r and zr back and forth
with a strong weapon near a hinox to
deal damage quickly sometimes before
they can even strike back
if you're up against a talus with a weak
spot on its backside you can make this
fight easier with a couple tools use a
simple korok leaf by attacking jumping
and dropping the bomb quickly this can
sneak the round bomb right between their
legs and detonate it behind them
knocking them down for an easy beating
guardians can be tougher for some new
players because of their oppressive
barrage of laser attacks if it ever
becomes too much though simply cast
magnesius into the air drop any material
on the ground and stand still to get a
breather this will make an invisible
barrier in front of you and you can even
do this on multiple sides if you're
surrounded combine this trick with the
whistle over and over to completely
freeze them in their tracks giving you a
window to strike them in their eye with
an arrow for easy damage
lionel's can be cheesed in a couple ways
depending on your equipment and where
you are the most common and obvious way
is to pummel their face with a
multi-shot arrow over and over waiting
until they shake their head and stun
them again but there are some other
methods such as bringing them near
shallow water imprisoning them in three
cryoness blocks then repeatedly mounting
and attacking it which while mounted on
lynels takes no durability to hit the
lynel but the setup can be a little more
finicky the more approachable trick is
to lasso them with the camera by waiting
until they run off then pointing the
camera downward to control their
movements they will continuously aim for
the top of the screen so just simply
guide them around you in a circle and
hit them with any weapon you'd like
while they're doing this
and the other thing to note is that
every enemy has a weak spot that's
easily struck in bullet time while there
are a multitude of advanced tricks to
get into bullet time whenever you want
make it a little bit easier to access by
simply setting up four bundles of wood
ahead of time to create a permanent
updraft once you have a quick and easy
way to access bullet time over and over
stunning them repeatedly becomes easy
peasy
there's your quick tips to take care of
hyrule's tougher foes if you enjoy a
breath of the wild content stick around
because we still cover this game to this
day like our recent coverage of the
evolution of breath of the wild's
advanced combat for anything else gaming
stick right here on gamespot
[Music]
you